hi I'm Sadashiva PI from science mission
so we have today dr. veena Joe from
University of Toledo with us she is a
distinguished University professor and
chair founding executive director Center
for hypertension and Christian medicine
she is also a principal investigator
programs in physiological genomeics dr.
Joe has won several awards to her credit
I'm going to mention only few of them
here because otherwise it will take
almost an hour to go through all of them
she's won President's Award for
outstanding scholar in the University of
Toledo in 2018 she is a distinguished
University professor 2017 she has won
President's Award for Excellence in
grantsmanship University of Toledo 2017
she also won niversity of Toledo College
of Medicine and life sciences dean's
award for research excellence in
sustainable research in 2015 several
more of them
so welcome dr. Joe to science hangout
hi nice nice to be talking on this
hangout because this is a new thing for
me so everybody out there hi okay
let's can you please talk about yourself
your background education etc I am
basically from India something here from
my source mother out of Bangalore I did
my complete education from kindergarten
to PhD in that town when I moved to
Delhi dance of science for my postdoc
for for a brief period and then came to
the NIH for my postdoc and after at the
turn of the century I moved to Toledo
yeah since for 18 years now so my career
path has been interesting I worked on
how to immune diseases for a while and
then latched on to genetics at the NIH
and move that aspect of it to Toledo
have been working on several complex
traits hypertension is prominent or what
you funded for and set up with this okay
and let's talk about your like a mentor
source people who supported in you in
during your career as you know there are
a lot of people who serve as mentors or
you grab them for their roles for what
they do
so my dual roles a scientist and
administrator have different mentors for
the science part of it a few people
including my graduate school mentor
doctor location from India and dr. Rapp
from genre video have been exceptional
mentors there are others that I can name
for the administrative aspects its dr.
Cooper who's the Dean of our school is
excellent I do look up to women as
mentors
internationally-acclaimed folks like
Anadolu reactor used to mention a few in
my best critic my husband who is Thank
You Buster or the University of Michigan
so that's a pain critic that I get how
all we do in exceptions in a wonderful
journey okay and other than research I
know you are busy with the research most
of the times other than research how
else you spend time like what are your
hobbies and off well I'm a I'm a trained
Indian classical dance professional so
vanadium uh-huh you over the weekend in
fact I have a picture for you to show in
my presentation I think pride in in
getting girls
mainly girls excited for women in STEM
through art so do a little research with
the art part of it too ok that's good
and like how big is your lab like a can
you talk about your projects and a lot
of people and are so let people are the
pudding that I get to eat for free they
are people
they're about seven graduate students
some graduated out somewhere in the lab
MD PhD students including there are few
postdoc faculty a big range of trainees
who basically run the show for science
at this age I think I'm receptive to
their creativity more than banking on my
own so my students are listening in they
don't know what I'm talking about it's
pretty obvious okay it brings more okay
and talk about some of the projects you
are doing and then we can go to your
presentation so why don't we switch to a
presentation because it kind of has okay
okay so we won't waste time doing that
now said okay okay good go ahead alright
so let's go on to presentation are you
seeing the slides now yes all silver
ketones hypertension is the one perfect
again I will try and make it concise if
it's not you can turn me up as you
please okay
anyway okay five minutes okay so the
topic I put out for today is salt labor
ketones and hypertension what are the
links the specific topic pertains to the
article that we published recently but
before getting into it in terms of
addressing how our lab is asking
different questions I'll go through some
of those initial work and transition
into this topic so first off this is the
picture is referring to my students they
brighten my life yes my daughter Megan
masseur kind of do it for her but all of
these are my people that keep my
artistic sense alive and brings when
they're coming to work on Mondays this
is what I come to order
from Monday through Friday an
exceptional group of individuals several
art students and postdocs so I will be
highlighting three papers one from Blair
as the first author the second one from
Sarah as his first author and the third
from cirrhosis the first author and the
rest are part of a team for all the
papers okay yeah go on
can you please hide that sharing stuff
like that yeah so that it doesn't block
yeah okay so over the years we have had
a number of collaborators I wish to
highlight dr. Vijay Kumar who is now
with us he came to us recently from Penn
State he's now the director of the
microbiome consortium with whom we work
very closely on the projects I'm going
to describe today for the latter part
the microbiome part so I have to give a
shout out to him and his team for the
exceptional work they do for us so this
is the paper which I'm very happy that
you showcase for us dr. Pye exactly as a
recent article on salt response in
metabolites beta-hydroxybutyrate
attenuates hypertension we talk about it
as the third paper so let me go back to
our roots we do work with blood pressure
and you may or may not know that there's
a new guideline based on a clinical
trial so anybody under 120 is normal
above that number in the US is
considered some stage of elevated blood
pressure so that has significantly cost
raised the number for percentage of
people who are a hypertensive for
example in Ohio that takes it up to 64
percent of adults in a high or high or
hypertensive but from our viewpoint
hypertension is a risk factor that has a
number of components one is genetics
environment and then everything else
that you can bend in one group we've
been focused on the genetics
evidence-based medicine suggests
everybody's
equal in genetics that's not true in
clinical realities we are all very
different and so the term precision
medicine is kind of attractive to go
towards future of medicine as you know
and we model it we model it in animals
for how they would behave with different
genes for their presentation of blood
pressure the animal model that we use in
the lab prominently is called the dolls
all sensitive hypertensive rats
these were in bred in Toledo we do study
not gene wars which is Association
studies we study genome-wide inheritance
which is familial transmission of genes
through this model for what causes
hypertension from the genetic viewpoint
we have used recent tools to sequence
the genome we know our finite set is a
cluster of 2 million base pairs that's
different but the tensor bread and the
resistant rat so this being the case
which ones are responsible for blood
pressure control in this animal is what
we are after
Amara's originated in Brookhaven
National Laboratory Louis Dahl was the
one who created the s rats he was
keeping output populations alive and we
brought it over to Toledo and in reddit
my predecessor John drafted it
so the histone history of it is salt has
always been a topic associated with this
all sensitive model but it always comes
up in new forms which is what we discuss
in our third paper today this is more of
about dr. Dahl it's a fascinating
history for how during World War two
science was still alive in in minds of
curious people so if you want to go
ahead and read this you get a personal
history of dr. talk and how the work has
come about using this model using this
model I'm going to you know go through a
few decades of work we have published a
lot trying to identify genes positional
clone them some of these papers are
highlighted here this is again our
history one of the most recent papers
that I
Cardiff is from my graduate students she
Chang who's never post up with us we
CRISPR engineered our 19 base pairs on
this rack and identified that those are
positionally cloned and nucleotides
contributing to blood pressure
regulation when we came to this point
question was what's translational how do
we go so it's a difficult world as you
know in genetics or even though we can
take it to final proof in models which
was what the question we asked initially
there's still a lot more work to do in
genetics we have reviewed all of this
and I'll highlight this review for you
it's pretty substantial for both human
hypertension and models if anybody's
interested to look at the genetic
aspects of what we do so this question
of which genome stared at us around 2014
call it kind of a midlife crisis I in
the lab looking at the mammalian genome
you're looking at a rat genome trying to
simulate what goes on in the human
genome but then we are thrown with this
idea that there is another big genome
collectively called the microbiome with
way more genes that's actually impacting
traits compared to human genome even
more so so do we call the microbiome as
a genetic aspect well you can question
that if you refer to the biome it's the
genes its genetic if you refer to the
biota it's more physiology so it's too
complex to go into the biome so we trust
our Dannette the biota has a question
as you know microbiota alter and almost
every facet of human life and the animal
life so there's a lot to study there I
don't have to harp on this at all except
to point out that when you look at
PubMed which we probably published this
chart not too long ago this is a graph
of number of publications versus years
for a search term microbiota in PubMed
you will see picked up around the turn
of the century because of sequencing
capabilities and has sharply risen for
all diseases
now when you subset it out for just
microbiota and hypertension you'll see
how tiny the number of publications are
it isn't updated but I can tell you more
than half are in views so there's not
much original work in linking microbiota
to biota to blood pressure as a trait so
we ask that fundamental question and
reported it first in 2015 that there is
a link between gut microbiota and
hypertension and the dog rat the right
we study this was highlighted in 2015 by
the EHA but they're not many worked on
it since so the numbers remain small for
publications
however it's catching on having made
that fundamental discovery I just want
to briefly report what that paper meant
for us the s and the our rats which are
the dogs are sensitive rats and the salt
resistant non hypotensive rats their
microbial compositions are different
that was the first observation but then
the question became if we swap these
microbiota to these animals will their
blood pressure change we did that
experiment we swapped gut microbiota
from a resistant ran to the s rat and
had an autologous control Y say versa s
to R and then autumn of this control and
the sickle transplant experiment gave us
this data so to the salt resistant rats
regardless of what microbiota you gave
their blood pressure remained unchanged
thus taluk blood pressure plotted here
went up highest for the r2s group
compared to the s2s group so pay
attention to this R is a normal tensive
rat from the microbiota off which will
be transferred to the susceptible
hypertensive rat the blood pressure of
this rat further increased so this gave
us an indication that there is some sort
of symbiotic relationship between the
gut microbiota and these animals that we
needed study it wasn't as if the
normotensive rat
protecting microbiota it had to do with
which rabbit was exposed to four effects
on blood pressure anyway we finished up
that paper doing short chain fatty acid
analysis which are metabolites of
microbiota as you know we found that in
the animals that had the race blood
pressure acetate was higher and Sobers
helped annoyed and these were early
years so we couldn't go any further than
this and we finished up that work with
the conclusion that there is a
definitive link we just need to mine
data more on what it is the concept also
evolved for us that some of the groups
were looking at Katrina axes and got
bone marrow access and we came up with
the hollow beyond concept to be front
and center for instead of looking at
these individual access for how
microbiota influenced blood pressure we
perhaps need to look at the whole
organism and identify newer ways of how
microbiota are impacting to change
normal blood pressure to hypertension
the second study what we did therefore
was with antibiotics as you know
antibiotics are bactericidal and so is
salt and salt increases blood pressure
to do what about antibiotics the simple
logic if it is true microbiota which
there was no data for at that time then
antibiotics should also have some impact
on blood pressure to a scarier thought
because of how often we use antibiotics
in our lives but that's the question we
ask to see what that means to
hypertensives so we took two strains of
rats I'm introducing the second strain
here first one is the S right which is
genetically hypotensive second is the
spontaneously hypotensive rat which was
selected without any salt diet but is
still hypotensive so we took two modules
and asked the question when we treat
them with antibiotics what happens to
their microbiota here you see the red
lines depict the alpha diversity which
is all lowered in
the Icicle only treated groups we had
three antibiotics minocycline you know
neomycin and vancomycin and as expected
you know their microbiota clusters were
different indicating that the
antibiotics were performing their job of
clearing gut microbiota selectively so
for what they target but what was
interesting was that in some of the rats
in the same rat strain the three
antibiotics did not work identical for
example in the s rat you will see that
the red line is the control blood
pressure of all the three increased but
in the SHR there was no effect of
neomycin but the other two antibiotics
decreased blood pressure so strain
specific effects of antibiotics in one
it it increases in the other it has
disparate effects so try to look at this
graph and think about us individuals we
are different for our antibiotic
sensitivities because we are genetically
wired differently for our susceptibility
to blood pressure which means we don't
know if we are hurting ourselves by
taking antibiotics or helping ourselves
by taking some antibiotics this is
actual persistent personalized medicine
for me in action demonstrated through
models so this was an important study
for us to point out that antibiotics
need caution for prescription by doctors
for hypotensive subjects who may have
different genetic profile propensities
again this is early time so we don't
know what this means in terms of
mechanism so the third study we saw we
I'm going to describe now we actually
thought of hidding mechanism a little
harder than what we are done with the
previous two studies so in this study we
asked the question does salt influence
blood pressure via the gut microbiome so
this is a nice diagram from a Nature
Reviews cardiology article where they
did mention the human
aspect which I talk to you about or what
we were doing and we're still continuing
to do but then we brought in the salt as
an environmental factor dietary factor
and asked the question well is the
genetic link of microbiota to the genome
impacted by an environmental agent and
so we said let's study salt so we looked
at the sound effects on our models first
off we fed rats a low salt diet or a
high-salt diet chart here in black is a
systolic blood pressure of an animal of
the group of animals that were on low
salt and this red line is that of high
salt as you can see this is not new data
when we eat salt blood pressure goes up
and this is very high in this model so
this is the model system in these
animals when we compared their
microbiota 9th and a different so
clusters bcoa plots indicate that there
are big differences when animals are
consuming high salt or low salt in their
gut microbiota so then we looked at
certain classes which once went up and
down lactobacilli shown here were lower
in the high salt group compared to the
low salt group this was not new data at
the time we were studying this there was
another group in Germany that did the
exact studies and published in nature
dahm dahm doctor Mueller's group that
this is what they observed as well so
for some what you know corroborated at
that point but we also noticed was that
in the high salt group proteobacteria
are lower and frevo tella is higher so
with these three there were other
changes but we kind of were looking at a
spread of what is altering and these
strucker's for changes the next question
we asked was because microbiota
alternative loans let's go ahead and
check the plasma of these rats for what
are the metabolites circulating in these
and how different are they so we did a
carbohydrate specific panel for honestly
I said independence reason that was just
the first one we said okay let's go
ahead and look at that what my graduate
student did very clever sir wrote was he
fasted the animals and then studied them
and here you're looking at a wall Kano
plot where you see the red dots are the
significant metabolites that were
different between the low and high salt
fed groups of animals we focused in on
beta hydroxy butyrate which was lower in
the high salt fat group this was I think
one of the highest differentially
expressed metabolites and because of the
fact I told you it was faster drats it
made a lot more sense to look at beta
hydroxy butyrate as you know is a
metabolite that is altered in calorie
restriction and fasting and exercise and
all of that but it had no known links to
blood pressure radiation so it was
interesting for us to pick this up for
further work the first experiment we did
was to confirm that this is all true so
we took the metabolomics data to heart
and measured what the actual plasma so
creating levels are so here you are
seeing beta hydroxy butyrate is
something and fed conditions of low and
high salt shown in black and red you
will see that in the fasted State we
were able to you know validate the
observation through the metabolomics
study and it was not significant in the
fed State now you can appreciate why the
fasting state was key for us to get to
this data so the next question we asked
is well if that's all true it must be
very simple for us to check if we ex are
jinnah Slee add this ketone body into
what's available in the rats body can we
lower its blood pressure we're asking a
tall order question but if there's a
link we should see some results here so
the way we approach this was to use
chemical called one three butanediol
which is an fda-approved drug for weight
loss and glucose control this is a
precursor of beta hydroxy butyrate so we
designed a study to feed the animals on
a high-salt diet with 1-3 butanediol to
observe their blood pressure before we
cut the blood pressure data we had to be
sure that this compound does convert
into beta hydroxy butyrate so after
garage we did measure their beta hydroxy
butyrate levels and you can see this is
a very high concentration it's 20%
volume by volume garage bought faster
than fed States it is remarkably high
which is what we wanted to do the
question then is this high level of pH B
does it then alter blood pressure and
indeed when we gave the animals won't
leave butanediol the line that you see
in purple here is the systolic blood
pressure of the group that received the
1-3 butanediol
despite being on a high-salt diet the
controls are just on high salt and
you'll appreciate it that there is a
significant dip at every time point for
systolic blood pressure this work this
is the money slide for there is
something profound happening when you
alter the ketone body in a rat - that
lowers its blood pressure question is
what did we do so magically that it
lowers his blood pressure okay all of
this information we then ran to the
patent office with it because this is
pretty exciting as a potential therapy
for soft sensitive high pretences the
next question was settling it back to
microbiota did what we observe was a due
to the changes in microbiota or not well
I can tell you we don't have an answer
it but I can tell you how we're going
about it the oral supplementation of one
three butanediol
also alters the gut microbiota as you
can see purple group is one with the
camp with the ketone body precursor and
the red one is just a high-salt group
and these are the PCO air plots coming
back to what the microbiota status was
this was just the comparisons to
reiterate to that this is the the top
panel is the difference we had with low
and high SARS that I had shown you
previously if you recall it lactobacilli
went down here lactobacilli appeared to
go up but didn't make statistical
significance Proteobacteria went down
but when we were giving the ketone body
it seems like it is getting reversed
Prevotella is went up in the low to high
salt comparison but when the high salt
group was given butanediol it's looking
like it's reversed so there are some
reversals but not the one that was in
focus with the other group publishing in
nature that lactobacilli in in fact were
altered by salt and feeding lactobacilli
rescues blood pressure may not work in
our model any and be the study that we
are conducting with ketone bodies and
focus may or may not work with
lactobacilli for us it looks like it may
not work so much with lactobacilli but
it may be associated with changes in
other microbiota that part of the study
is still not complete but we will be
working on these aspects for knowing the
links between microbiota and ketone
bodies of the hosts regardless we still
had to answer how we blood pressure was
lowered in these animals given ketone
body precursor so first we checked the
obvious spots to check which our gut
permeability or serum immuno reactivity
to microbial products none of them were
different between the three groups that
we were studying low salt high salt or
high salt plus on three butanediol
so we concluded that alterations in gut
permeability do
explained that blood pressure
differences observed rescue observed
with 1/3 butanediol fragile in or
anti-flood Yulin and anti LPS levels
which are microbial products anti ba
anti products formed by the host or not
alter souls it's not true
bacterial reactivity that this blood
pressure difference is explained then we
looked at what I'm not showing here is
the th17 profiles that they were also
not different I'm just keeping that data
well what we found however was a very
nice correlation between nlrp3 levels
now you're looking at high salt and high
salt rated with 1:3 butanediol groups
nlrp3 in the reno tissue is lowered cast
1 is lowered and so are il 18 and il-1
beta and here you are seeing the protein
level serum il-1 beta so all of these
data indicated that there is a
inactivation of the nlrp3 inflammasome
in the presence of 1-3 buting diode and
that isn't new because PHP is known to
inactivate nlrp3 inflammasome what is
new is that this is operational to
control blood pressure is the new aspect
of it so then we went ahead and did some
renal histology here you're seeing the
renal injury score being lowered the
protein casts that excuse me and
fibrosis in blue are all significantly
lower compared to the top panel which is
the high salt group in the lower panel
is the one treated with 1-3 butanediol
so there's a rescue of renal function
renal architecture anatomy and
physiology we also went ahead and looked
for macrophage infiltration as you can
see the brown staying here in the high
salt group or macrophages infiltrating
the renal tissue and that's all lowered
in the treated group
and this is a quantitative score
indicating that well the kidney is
probably better and therefore
infiltration of macrophages is lower and
this lowering of improvement in kidney
function is one of the ways by which
blood pressure lowering could be
impacted so that's the paper we wrote
which a kidney in focus for cell reports
and the key points here are that the the
new aspects are the diet dietary salt
excuse me alters plasma
beta-hydroxybutyrate meaning it lowers
it and thereby we see a correlation for
increased in blood pressure we sought to
correct the plasma levels by a
nutritional intervention with the
precursor of beta hydroxy butyrate and
then we observed lowering of blood
pressure but then we followed the
mechanism through the kidney we are able
to demonstrate that we are in activation
of the nlrp3 inflammasome by blocking it
lowering all the downstream mediators we
are able to observe three key parameters
lowering of serum sodium potassium ratio
lowering of proteinuria and lowering of
renal injury score which are all known
features for contributing to blood
pressure and therefore we interpret that
this rescue of renal function is what is
lowering blood pressure mechanistically
this is just one article bhp has
influence on other tissues so right now
we are focusing on other tissues for
what and how it could impact for example
the brain blood vessels etc for how that
that would also contribute to blood
pressure regulation the key part that i
want you to focus on is the diagram here
of the liver from what we have read
about hypertension I don't think ever is
a prominent organ that we study in the
pressure regulation so here is an ounce
of data to consider that liver may
prominently contribute to
regulation it may also link the aspects
of metabolic syndrome wherein
hypertension presents as a significant
risk factor so there are more studies to
be conducted for how the liver may
impact hypertension the take-home
message from this third paper is shown
in this cartoon here you have a nice
balance between salt and bhp and which
is beta-hydroxybutyrate
normal blood pressure which could be
tipped in conditions of hypertension
which are due to elevated salt and in
that same condition our observation was
that beta-hydroxybutyrate is lowered and
our experiments have proved that by
rescuing this back we are able to
control blood pressure regain normalcy
as best as we can
stated despite the usage of high salt by
the animal in its diet so when you
relate this back to what happens in
exercise in exercise B or HB is higher
is elevated in exercise so the one of
the ways by which exercise may help
hypertensive despite their salt
consumption could be because they
elevate their vita hydroxy butyrate
levels so what we are suggesting is
doesn't matter the means if it's either
to exercise or calorie restriction or
fasting all of these conditions increase
bhp or by nutritional intervention means
like we suggest to take a bolus of Bo HB
or its precursor it may be a way to
think about controlling salt sensitive
hypertension in humans the other part to
consider is if this is impacting many
tissues we may not have to look for
selective agents that target exclusively
the kidney or the blood vessel or brain
or other organ specific therapeutics
that are in the market for blood
pressure control we may be looking
at a global impact on several tissues in
one go which all benefits to keep blood
pressure normal so that would be one way
of you know igniting thinking for how
the liver could impact blood pressure
regulation so bringing it all front and
center I think two more minutes we
started out with this slide that we were
working on the genetics for each
individual is different and therefore
they genetic compositions may have to be
carefully evaluated for future doctors
to look at their DNA blueprints and
overlaid with environmental factors or
preventing treating addressing
hypertension in the clinic however a new
factor is the microbiome which is also
highly variable between individuals the
meta balloons are also variable are
there groups subgroups that we can
target with data on Metra balloons and
microbiome data in hypertensives well
that's a question to address and in the
lab currently we are slowly moving in
that direction for addressing that exact
question as shown here for what's the
translational significance of knowing
that certain metabolites are altered or
certain microbiota are altered in
individuals we are currently recruiting
subjects for a study that we have an IRB
approval for already what we are looking
for are people with high blood pressure
and people with a normal blood pressure
to compare the two groups to study their
roles of their bacteria and metabolites
circulating in their bodies to see if
there's any association for these two
factors as we can as we study in our
models so the phone number is here and
the email contact is here for whoever is
listening if you could pay attention to
how important it would be for us to
collect these data please reach out to
us we'll be very grateful to you for
doing so
with that I think I'm done I can take
questions if ready okay you can just get
out of this representation more
double-click yeah I want to see if there
are few people on the this thing if I
want if anybody is interested in asking
any questions okay let me out of this
already now not yet it is just going but
I don't see you you should be seen on
the screen basically one thing you can
do is there is it on the left side
screen share double click on that okay
yeah second yeah here you go
okay thank you so much it's it's a
pretty interesting and I have glanced
through that your cell reports paper
recently so which is which is pretty
interesting I have few questions if you
don't mind one is a you look at the
metabolome right yes can you hear me
since the yeah I can hear you can you
yes okay let the metabolome like since
the bacteria in the gut have you looked
at me urinary components or the fecal
things which is changing or anything
happening with that so the reporters for
what's in the gut we have used only
fecal material in some of our studies we
have you see Co samples in others we
have used Pico samples so that we have
not looked at urinary microbiome yet I'm
not talking about the microbiome I'm
talking about the metabolites like when
you add salt and all there will be
changes in the metabolites which might
be secreted in the urine and fecal you
found that beta hydroxy butyrate from
the serum right so I'm just thinking
like is there anything coming out from
the urine or in the fecal matter
something comes out which could be other
made to look at it so you you find very
well taken
if I can fast forward that thought can
be used which elbows in the urine or
stool samples as biomarkers would be one
way of looking at it for the extent we
have not done it for whether the initial
report we haven't what we are doing
right now is to titrate the amount of
bhp that is really required for the
observed physiological change in blood
pressure and in that context we will
have to monitor what you just mentioned
in the urine okay and the other question
is like the fiber right fiber plays a
role in changes in the microbiota and
all those things so have you looked
because an fiber also like some people
say it will decrease your blood pressure
- like if you add fiber to your food so
have you looked into that or anybody
else has looked into that in terms of
looking at the blood pressure microbiome
and fiber content so you're asking
questions for other projects in the lab
I'm just giving some ideas we are
looking at the effects of fiber we I
don't think is reasonable to err in this
context because we that's fine that's
fine Gina and there is also dietary
additives we are looking at some of them
used in ancient Indian culinary not
ancient even now like curcumin and
capsizing we're looking at the effects
of those very carefully but if because
we know they're all anti-inflammatory -
in addition to being antibiotic plus how
do they then operate in the context of
diet for influencing blood pressure
there are indications similar to fiber
for some of these food additives to
alter blood pressure but there's no
rationale like big evidence from the
microbiota frontier so that's an area of
you're working with so appreciate your
question on the fiber aspect and last
one would be like you talked about the
brain right like what happens beta
hydroxy butyrate and all those things
and there are recent reports in I think
in science or nature somewhere
cell-like there is direct connection
between the brain I mean like the
gastric intestinal nerve endings with
the brain so it directly communicates
with the brain and certainly brain plays
a role in the hypertension and all those
things modulating the adrenal glands and
all those stuff so how are you looking
in that direction to like because since
it is microbiota its I think it is like
I'm just thinking it I mean thinking in
terms of openly about the whole thing
dr. Bai you're spot-on with that
question because beta-hydroxy rate is
known to I mean it is an alternate fuel
for the brain so there are reports that
bhp consumption keeps the brain alive or
so I'm saying it in layman's terms what
we are learning is that our animals on
1/3 butanediol are active so we are
looking into the brain functionality
part of it to see our cognition could be
affected and you know the brain has a
huge impact on blood pressure regulation
I was alluding to other tissues brain is
also in it for how that might impact
blood pressure through the alteration of
ketone bodies I want to serve my
question just for did you find me yeah
sure good yeah dr. Vijay Kumar has
recently published a cell paper right
you're on that as collaborators what we
are looking at is the fiber aspect of it
so the specific animal model that was
presented there is the toll receptor 5
knockout mouse the initial study from
his previous work in science
demonstrates that tlr5 knockout have
elevated hypertension but when the same
animals are given soluble fiber they
have effects on liver cancer so soluble
if you put it into context of blood
pressure regulation there is an aspect
of it that we may be able to work with
with the tol 5 receptor
knockout mice I would recommend a
hangout with dr. Kumar slab - I'm
thinking of my list yeah it would be
nice the next step
yeah but he never put in a word for me
I'm going to contact him within next
because he is in another state and
people I'm supposed to contact for this
anger yeah I'll send him an email - in
the next few days but if you could put
in a word that also and one more the
last one is like ketone bodies are like
you have when you eat lot of fatty food
like it's a fat right when you digest
that there is lot of ketone bodies so
how does it like relate like if you had
a obese person you have a higher amount
of like people say if you are higher
like your hypertension goes up but there
would be more of ketone bodies I would
assume I don't know I haven't looked
into literature or anything like that I
would assume there would be more ketone
bodies in there how does it cause oral a
more deep but needs to be looked into
there but just I'm curious to figure out
like if you have thought about that
secondly you have certainly is not true
because your viewpoints are coming in as
important for us to consider when you
mentioned the objects their ketone body
levels are higher or lower oh yeah oh
yeah I would say because there is more
fat for but fat metabolism would be
higher compared to see normal people
because of the higher fat content
yeah that is new information for me per
se we'll have to look into that there
are two ways Neri from a hypertension
researcher point of view not all obese
people are hypertensive not all our
normal tensive normal tyson yeah
disconnect there and perhaps connection
in some subset so one way design
experiments for testing what you said
would be to feed high fat diets to
understand
ketone body regulation in a high fat
diet context
models have to be carefully thought
about for which ones to study yeah I
think I have I don't have any more
questions so I really appreciate you
taking time to do this I'm sure you are
busy thank you so much and if anything
comes up in next few months or a year
give me a hall so we can do another
hangout thanks so much
no no it's basically there are few
people three four people are viewing it
what happens is like it will be on the
website once it is done once I stop it
automatically it goes to our website
anybody can watch it and they can like
there is a window there like if they
want they have any questions they can
ask questions basically like they can
directly in touch with you basically
well thank you so much for this
opportunity I've had fun doing this and
hopefully if there are questions we'll
be happy to answer them yeah certainly
thank you so much
keep in touch yeah